everyone knows Hawaii as a tropical
paradise with cranky volcanoes and
fabulous white sand beaches what most
people don't realize is that those
beaches are almost entirely composed of
fish poop that's right you heard me fish
poop enter the parrotfish a bizarre
creature with an appetite for the algae
that grows on coral the fish should nas
the stuff off with those beak like teeth
but in the process also strips calcium
carbonate from the reef and I'm talking
a lot of it a single pair of fish can
eat enough calcium carbonate to produce
800 pounds of sand a year and over in
Australia another species can lay down a
ton of it like literally a ton of it but
if you can believe it pooping out
beaches isn't even the most intriguing
thing about the parrotfish it's sleeping
bag of snot is like a narcoleptic that's
accidentally taken sleeping pills the
parrotfish is an unusually heavy sleeper
and that might put it in danger of
predation as a countermeasure it'll tuck
itself into the reef and its creep a
balloon of mucus this bubble could serve
to mask its scent or work as an alarm
when a predator bumps against it
parrotfish also gets busy in a very
bizarre way all of them are actually
born female and then join a school but
as they grow the largest female will
transform into a male and adopt a
beautiful color scheme now he's got
himself a harem but he keeps watch over
chasing away rival males with a mind to
get with his ladies all of them
constantly making sand for the next time
you're enjoying a beautiful lion Beach
raise an umbrella drink to the drowsy
pair
maybe think about putting those sandals
back on